hello and welcome to a new game
here on the channel
but white again playing pirate 52
so b5
to do this here a couple of options but
i think this is interesting
i checked this um actually for keep it
simple deform
okay
so so it looks a little bit trollish
what black is doing what kind of account
is that nice got tons of blitz games
just
[Music]
only blitz nothing else okay so let's go
a4
now what do we do see c3 here maybe
attack this
looks like a quick development then
like takes knight takes i'm not sure
that knight takes actually best honestly
b takes also looks fine with queen b3
coming with a tempo
it looks better even actually
i i don't expect that move though i
expect a5
something something more ambitious
knight f3 b5 is an interesting move
actually it has a really bad reputation
but i'm not so sure about e4 bishop b7
then
yeah something says something more
ambitious like that was also what i
expected
the question is now do we want to take
on c5 or what are we doing here
taking this also looks um promising in
my mind
and i wonder maybe he wants to know i
thought he maybe wants to take on
d4 move a5 is interesting in this
position
that's a tough one you want to invest
this tempo
and isolate the b4 pawn here
like when this is on a5 there has he has
no natural way to cover
cover the pawn okay
it's knight h5 something that should
worry me
not sure but i'm going to invest this
move
or invest the time for this move is
probably better english
it's a bit surprising
okay um so i can check
it makes sense actually i'm not saying
it's a bad move
but it blunts my bishop so okay i'm
going to check him
first
now yeah knights b3 or knight c4
it's the thing okay i will castle first
that's
uh necessary anyway
what am i doing with the knight on f3
this is interesting
probably this knight should go to c4m
at the end of the day so i'm not playing
knight c4 here i could have done that
actually
anyway
i cannot allow knight tx g3 so
i can make this move first and then
think about details
the issue here for black is the a5 pawn
it's always attacked
with by the knight and a natural move
like
rook c8 is not possible okay
um interesting
now he's attacking my paw but i want to
get rid of his centralized knight so
this move is kind of natural
it takes it queen takes
bishop d5
it should d5 maybe yeah
queen d3 was my idea
keeping this covered
and maybe i get an e4 here
yeah e4
pushing this bishop back
okay that's a radical solution
maybe not a bad solution
so rook c2 maybe
just claiming that i'm a little bit
quicker on the c file right
the 8 rook c1
i can i completely forgot that he has
rooks he ate him
interesting
so i take it and then i go all the way
to d3
right here
what is this position is this equal or
okay
if he takes it okay did not
okay i guess
yeah this is an interesting situation
here
i wonder what what this is
equal or if he has
if i have something maybe not
slightly surprising that he is playing
like this
maybe maybe maybe it's fine
could be yes
it's very concrete i mean
very concrete if we get something with
the e pawn going or not
king f6
[Music]
um
i'd like to of course get this
pawn in motion i
have an outside passer potentially
probably still a draw i don't see how i
can get g5 going he has a fortress in
some way
with the with this interesting maybe
there were some chances
i think um right out of the opening
i should have had some advantage
so okay h form something
i mean black's opening play is certainly
risky but i was
erring on the conservative side here h4
is certainly possible
but this is just a good structure right
so let's just i just want to see if um
a5 was possible but this is still
looking pretty good
kind of curious
when it starts to just be okay any more
here already
yeah and now he just goes for this maybe
i can just play bishop a6 here as well
or bishop
c6 hmm that makes a lot of sense
bishop c6 this is actually
kind of an echo move of karpov's bishop
a7 right
against unsicker the game from the
nice olympiad 1974 and carpet was
playing bishop
a7 on the a file and then doubled behind
it
and this is the same thing i play this
and then i double behind it
it's funny yeah well okay this is a very
classy move that i mean i would find
that for sure in a
in a longer time control game
but not not here
yeah i mean this is just keeping some
advantage but it's nothing special
we need four it's good here we're being
more aggressive
i was not playing aggressively in this
game or the game before really
it was just like content with keeping an
advantage
and here this is kind of fizzling even
though i feel i should have something
here here so i took it
bishop takes so i know king c
form of course i can go to
ah that was silly that was silly really
now
now i see it immediately because the
thing is if i go here
he has to do this first and yeah of
course
and then it's a tempo and then it gets
me here
that is that's just probably over right
it's a pretty awful oversight
and after b3 it's over right yeah in
terms of an advantage
maybe after he was a bit ambitious there
maybe there was something
[Music]
somewhere here
i doubt it it's really almost impossible
to get um and get a passer really
in motion or bishop f5 is much stronger
because that actually gets the passer
yeah i don't get it here because
he manages to go to c5 yes
so i have to go here and then i
actually get this in with the bishop
here i prevent
the knight coming to d7 i am okay
and that is very strong like this
this is strong knight d5 is not really
an issue because the knight is far away
from
attacking anything here and then i get
the pawn rolling
that should win and here he he got
got there just in time this is really
just a draw there's nothing
nothing to do there yeah
i miss some chances not playing actively
enough okay guys
thanks for watching